hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game it's from
the last uh it's the last game from the
day two uh of the creation grant just to
wrap it it's yanni palmision versus even
character the the highest rated player
in croatia and two of them have very uh
something very interesting in common
they had they both have a positive score
against magnus in classical chess
uh after facing magnus more than once uh
well we
we've checked out the nepo's games
against magnus but even here
uh he defeated magnus with the white
pieces in the thrones olympiad in 2014
and he drew against magnus uh
in the tata steel with the uh with the
black pieces in 2015. so this game
it's really an awesome one and it's
really a top tier game so i'm sure
you're going to enjoy it
uh let's check it out so nepo is still
leading the tournament and now
if he beats even he can really prolong
his uh lead
so nipple with the white pieces opens
with e4
sorry about that uh we have
c5 by even going for the sicilian
defense knight to f3 e6
ending now d4 so striking in the center
c captures knight captures and denounce
knight
to f6 we have knights to c3 and now
knight to c6
uh we have knight b to d5 knight d to b5
now
with some ideas of maybe knight to d6
check but of course we have just
d6 bishop to f4 by nipple now going
after this pawn it's attacked three
times and here
uh even just place e5 chases away the
bishop uh if this
uh we have uh bishop back to g5
interestingly it's a similar position to
if you're
if you know the game anderson versus
morphe except the knight was
still back here and uh anderson uh
launched forward
with it with f5 but here we have no such
crazy moves we have bishop to g5 now
uh and now comes a6 chasing away this
knight
we have knights to a3 even though you
could capture here you can capture
because if the queen captures the knight
to c7 check but black is very happy
capturing with the g pawn as it's uh
well
similar in in many such lines of the
sicilian defense later you can use the
semi-open g file for attacks you can
play e5 attack white center
so it's really really good for uh for
black so instead
after this a6 move we have knight to a3
and now
even goes b5 now threatening b4 to win
one of the knights on knight to d5
and now bishop to e7 uh and only now
bishop captures an f6 here nipple
eliminates the knight uh he gives up uh
the bishop pair uh but he will be left
with this very strong knight on d5 that
even will have to take care of later on
so bishop captures here
and now knight and up on the c3 nepo
will
now use the c2 square to get the knight
back into the game
so here we have bishop to g5 uh you want
to attack this knight with knight to e7
but if you do it right away then we will
capture an f6 and mess up black's pawn
structure and here it will be good for
white
so instead bishop to g5 now we have this
plan and this knight will not be able to
capture on f6 and also this bishop will
be very strong on this diagonal
as you'll see later on so knight to c2
nepo prepares to bring the
knight into the game knight to e7 and
now we have knight to b4 now saying okay
if you capture here
i can even capture with my queen and
it's it's a pretty interesting uh
idea if captures captures the rook is
under attack and what do you do you
can't really defend it so you have to
move the rook and if rook b8
now you don't play knight to c6 because
then bishop to b7
uh with pin the knight you actually
capture on a6 and this is uh
very good for white captures here queen
c6 check we're gonna pick up the bishop
and the white is
well just better at some point you can
easily create a pass pawn here start
pushing it
and uh hope to win the game uh so after
this knight see the b4 move we have
castles by shahrich
and now g3 uh nipple now ready to
develop his light square bishop
uh and now there is one game in the
database where a5 was played and it
makes sense you want to dislodge this
knight and then capture here the problem
is
after a5 uh white can simply capture on
e7 and after queen captures knight d5
this knight takes its place and
black hasn't really achieved all that
much even though
uh this is uh this is one of the
engine's
favorite uh ideas but we have bishop to
e6 by even
and it is only now as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
how nipple deals with this move
uh well nipple starts the attack right
away h4
uh chasing away this bishop we have
bishop to h6 now still
keeping control of this entire diagonal
and bishop to g2
we have a5 now attacking this knight and
now
knight captures on e7 uh we have queen
captures on e7
and now knight comes to d5 and here uh
the knight again
finds his place on d5 and well black
slide square bishop for the moment
is is fine where it is you do not want
to capture if you capture capture
uh then uh well black is just left with
a weak backwards d6 pawn later on you
can easily attack it
pile up on it you can even castle bring
the other rook into the attack
so it's uh this should be a problem for
black so instead after knight to d5 we
have queen to b7 by even
uh and now comes uh g4 nepo says all
right
i'm just gonna play g5 and trap your
bishop so even has to do something
now he could play f6 and try to stop
this attack but
even knows the old saying that you know
uh
never play f6 uh although you you can
play it in some positions
but even in those positions where you
can play it it's very hard to play it so
here he just captures on the e5
and he goes straight into the end game
uh if if he captures it shouldn't be a
problem
we can keep this bishop on f4 and it
should be a good a good position for
black
so instead after bishop captures we have
queen captures and here
uh even just trades queens captures
captures and then now bishop to f4 and
now we have this endgame
uh same amount of everything except the
bishops are of opposite colors and uh
whenever you have a case of bishops of
opposite colors you want to start
attacking your opponent because then if
uh
he has to defend then you will have
three pieces for attacking two rooks and
the bishop
and he will have only two rooks for
defense as the your opponent's dark
square bishop will not be able to oppose
your own light square bishop so here
king e2 as usual in the end game you
have to bring
your king forward we have rook 8 to b8
and now a3 preventing b4 from being
played
we have g6 now and of course h5 you gave
him a target so now nippo of course
wants to attack it with king the g7
and rook the h3 now adding a rook to the
defense of the third rank but also maybe
some
with some ideas of doubling up on the h
file so
rook f the c8 now preparing to bring the
rook maybe to c4
uh and now king to d3 we have king to f6
and now h captures on g6 we have h
captures in the rook to h7 so nepo gains
a lot of activity for his rook
but now rook to c7 we defend here and
now
bishop to e4 so what do you play here
well even goes king to g5 he says all
right
uh there's an active king but there's
also a two active king and
well let's let's see which one is this
uh and nipple says okay you can have
this pawn i'm just gonna play king to e2
and now the problem is
uh if even grabs this pawn he's getting
checkmated because if king captures you
just bring the rook to g1
with check and the king has no squares
the bishop and the rook cover all of
these squares so you have to block with
the bishop and then just captures king
f4
and now of course rook to h4 will be
checkmate so even not about to fall for
that
he uh strikes with b4 and now uh okay
uh he's ready to bring the rook not the
c2 of course the bishop covers that but
he will gain control of the c
file so here c captures on b4 we have
eight captures on b4 and now
a4 uh he gives nipple the past a pawn
but now
b3 he frees up the b for square for the
rook
and well black will have a lot of
activity here so kink to
f3 and now comes rook to b4
putting pressure along the entire fourth
rank and also just attacking this pawn
so you might even win it with something
like rook a7 rook captures here if
white does not continue pushing this
pawn forward which nipple does nipple
plays a5 he says
all right i'm just gonna promote this
pawn to a queen and it's
it's a win for me however this position
is completely lost for nipple
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this brilliant idea
for even while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible exchange sacrifice and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's rook captures an e4 and this is
just crushing
and an extra round of applause for those
of you who founded this move but also
figured out that
the rook cannot be captured then you
truly are
a master of of this game because if the
rook is captured well then we just play
f5 check and then we win
white's rook uh stranded on h7 for
example captures capture so we can even
keep harassing the white king with e4
let's say checking e2 and then we pick
up this
and there's no way to promote this if a6
we're just going to block it with rook
to a7
and i mean black is up a piece so of
course completely winning for black
so after rook captures an a4 nipple just
continues pushing
a6 he knows that even will have to give
up his rook to stop the past pawn
uh so here rook to d4 getting the rook
out of harm's way now
a7 and now we have e4 with check now
even starts attacking the white king
king the g2 and now you have to give up
the rook for the
uh for the past pawn otherwise you're
just lost so rook captures we have rook
captures
uh not right away first we had e4 check
of course sorry about that e4 check
king to g2 and now rook captures on a7
we
rook captures on a7 and now rook to d2
and now we have this position
where it's uh well five pawns against
four and even has a bishop and the rook
against two rooks but
well you can't really allow e3 to pick
up this pawn so you have to defend this
and then you're going to lose this pawn
so even will be up at least three pawns
so here king f1
you cannot allow e3 and now rook
captures on b2 and now we have this
awesome pass pawn on b3
rook to b7 now nipple has to play rook
to h8 rook to be it and try and win this
spawn
but even is ready for that he plays king
captures on g4
we have rook to h8 and now bishop to e5
the bishop will now guard the b2 square
the rook will move with tempo as the
king is here so we can deliver check
and then we're going to play pawn to b2
where the bishop will be nicely guarding
this past pawn
so rook h to b8 and now rook the b1
with king to g2 and now b2
so now it doesn't matter that nipple has
two rooks because the bishop on e5 is
protected and it guards the the
the pass pawn so at some point nipple
will have to give up uh
the the rook for the spawn and bishop so
rook captures an f7
he can grab a pawn on the other side of
the board but now rook to d1
threatening to promote this pawn to a
queen so now nepo has to go back to keep
an eye on the b1 square
and now rook captures on d5 again even
up three pawns we've rooked to b4
attacking this one but just king f5 and
now you just have to
put your pieces on optimal squares for
example put the king somewhere here and
then start advancing this pawn
and that should be game so can nipple
prevent this we have rook to f8 to check
kink the e6 rook the e8 to check king d7
and now rook has to go back
and like we said in yesterday's video uh
there's a certain feeling you get when a
player starts
checking like uh like mad so rook to d1
now
uh and uh rook f4 to b7 again uh keeping
uh
the black king in check king to e6 now
rook captures on b2 there is no other
move you can play
uh because now well the king is in
perfect position now the pawn will just
start marching forward
and that's it so here nipple has to give
up the rook for bishop and pawn
and now he will try to hold this being
down two pawns so d5
and now rook to b8 by nipple we have d4
but now rook to g8 going after this pawn
so even defends it
but now rook their fate going after
ivan's king king to g5
now rook to e8 going after this pawn so
even again defends it now rook to f8
check we have king e5 and rogue back the
e8 check so maybe maybe
you can somehow hold this by attacking
this pawn
however now king d5 rooked the g8 now
even gives up the pawn
but he just plays d3 uh so rook captures
on g6 just the d2 and there's no
stopping this because there's no
there's no check the king covers this
square and even if there was
it wouldn't really do do him any good so
here we have rook to g8 and now even
just continues in a
in a calm way with king to c4 but you
could also end it
instantly with rook to g1 that's also
possible just king captures and d1 queen
check
uh but even prefers to do it the other
way around king c4 we have rook to d8
and
now king the c3 and now nepal saw that
even was just
you know keeping it cool not rushing
into anything and of course it was in
this position almost 63
uh that uh yanipon she resigned the game
it's always
sad when uh you know people resign on
move 63 as
the chessboard has 64 square so i always
you know if you're almost 6
63 play one more move you know just just
for
those people who who have a problem with
such things but yeah
here after king the c3 he resigned and
the brilliant victory for evan
who now uh is in the top of the
tournament sharing second place with
um let me just quickly check i don't
have the standings here so i'm gonna
have to check it
uh the good old fashioned way for you so
niepo still leading with a tournament
even with this loss with 8
out of 12 and then we with 7 out of 12
we have three people vishwanathan
and the maximum and even charity uh then
with six points
uh we have anish geary and young shisht
of duda with five points uh mamidar of
grishok and korobo
uh with four points uh uh we have uh
jordan one forest and
that's it for the uh for the standing so
yeah really awesome game
uh really hoping uh to show at least one
more uh round from yes
one more game from yesterday as there
were a lot of really cool cool games so
feel free to use hashtag suggestion and
of course i will go through them
so a very very impressive game by both
of them and even was
again able to take down another very
strong player this time the world chase
championship candidate uh
so congratulations on that uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank cody tewtipu uh
kevin keith robert taratone and jim
and al boyd for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day